pour éviter que la violence et le
racisme continue de dénaturer le
football français nicolas sarkozy a
annoncé toute une série de mesures avec
effet immédiat la plus marquante pour le
psg et de restreindre la vente de ces
places aux associations officielles de
supporteurs préféré des gradins vides
pour éliminer les risques de dérapage si
fréquent romain messier et maris cazaux
la violence dans le foot s'est imposé
dans l'agenda de nicolas sarkozy réunit
en urgence ce matin les dirigeants du
football français du psg mais aussi les
associations de supporters du club pour
en arriver à une conclusion nous ne
voulons plus de racistes dans les stades
nous ne voulons plus de salut nazi nous
ne voulons plus de cris de singe quand
un joueur de couleur touche le ballon
nous voulons dépasser les stades
définitive pour cela cinq mesures
décidées ce matin
outre une réunion avant chaque match
entre groupes de supporters et forces de
police
le psg doit dorénavant réservé les
billets des tribunes boulogne et auteuil
aux seules associations officielles les
autres supporters n'auront plus accès
nous préférons tous voir certaines
tribunes vides que de les voir remplies
avec des gens indésirables
troisième mesure l'augmentation du
nombre de supporters interdits de
pénétrer au parc des princes 70
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus dans quelques
semaines autre sanction la répétition de
matches à huis clos en cas de
débordements enfin la dissolution des
groupes de supporters violents
prévue depuis un an devrait bientôt être
appliqué des mesures pour l'avenir mais
aucune sanction immédiate après le drame
de jeudi dans une semaine au parc des
princes les supporters de boulogne
montré du doigt seront toujours là
à